[Musique]
le soulagement de nicolas sarkozy la
vérité éclate enfin écrit l'ancien
président de la république après le
rétropédalage on peut le dire de ziad
takieddine cause de sarkozy n'a pas eu
un financement allait bien pour la
campagne présidentielle ni monsieur
kadhafi ne pouvait le faire parce qu'il
ne la faisait jamais c'est quelqu'un qui
monte très vite en pression qui
s'emporte assez facilement qui estime
que les accusations comporte contre lui
sont scandaleuses enfin très moyennes
orientales
1 comment le départ moi je m'interroge
quand même pourquoi est ce que nicolas
sarkozy a été mis sous contrôle
judiciaire et que ce fameux ziadia sedin
qui a été quand même condamné dans l'
affaire karachi lui n'étaient pas sous
contrôle judiciaire et s'est retrouvé en
café c'est partir ou liban on a toujours
deux trois qui étaient là pour dieu mais
non c'est idiot il y aura jamais
deuxième vague de gens qu'on prêtait le
même serment que moi géante
cette poignée de personnes effectivement
comme et erreur après erreur ne corrige
jamais je n'ai jamais rien et verse dans
le complotistes qu'elle n'agirait pas
des responsables mais je les
qualifierait de péremptoire il fallait
être humble et pour nous les médecins
ça va être et je l'espère une très très
grande leçon d'humilité
si vous voulez des noms c'est simple ces
messieurs peron toussaint tubiana et
même notre professeur didier raoult qui
comme erreur après le professeur raoul
fait l'objet de prises de poursuites
pardon devant l'ordre des médecins pour
une série dans thor son code de
déontologie notamment information
erronée du public
exposition à un risque en justifier même
charlatanisme
alors qu'il y avait beaucoup d'études et
que la plupart des pays avaient arrêté
d'utiliser l'hydroxyde l'europe chine
parce qu'il y avait la preuve que ça
fonctionnait pas il a continué voire
même renforcé sa tentative de l'imposer
dans les pratiques et c'est une pratique
est dangereuse il ya un virus qui
progresse de manière planétaire c'est le
complotisme alors monsieur raout il ya
en partie participer il a surtout été
utilisé par les complotistes
ils vous disent nommé raout c'est de sa
faute ainsi en afrique on l'a prescrit
ce gris clair vous avez vu des résultats
en afrique on n'a pas honte là on n'a
pas un peu honte là l'afrique s'en sort
considérablement dans le ton les cats
home devait s'annoncer en afrique tout
le monde disait que l'afrique
allez mon dieu paix
lourd tribut à cette crise elle est
celle qui s'en sort le mieux j'ai été
extrêmement choqué que l'un de vos
confrères
pascal praud effet et reçu le producteur
de cette chose que je n'ose pas appeler
documentaire qui est un ramassis de
toutes les thèses complotistes les plus
inquiétantes qui soit ça va de la remise
en cause de la dangerosité du virus
on a des certificats de décès que j'ai
pu constater dans dans la mairie où je
partais j'appartiens à savoir des
personnes très âgées qui sont décédés
marquer coved 19
or il n'y a jamais de crevettes 19 c ces
patients se confesse un procès
d'intention ce qu'on fait je vais vous
dire ce qu'on fait on fait le procès de
l'excellence face à la médiocrité
on ne sait pas pourquoi mais il ya une
surmortalité qui existe dans les
certificats médicaux j'ai posé la
question à monsieur salomon mais il m'a
dit qu'il regarderait ça en détail
nous avons donc décidé ce matin de
maintenir inchangés au moins pour les 15
prochains jours
les règles du confinement vous avez un
doute mais pardonner et donc donc on ne
reçoit pas le réalité on n'en débat pas
on met ça saoule n'y avait pas de débat
on le re souvient pas des français qui
s'interroge on n'essaie pas de les
convaincre ou d'avoir un débat contrat
du temps pour cela
oui il est forcément une radiation mais
alors la radiation n'interviendra pas
raul 3e série fut évidemment raul sera
relaxé en tout cas moi vivant rajoutera
relaxez vous vous mettez en danger en
vous et vous seul espace k mais la
liberté n'était que je maîtrise aussi la
situation de mise en danger que nous
avons la liberté aussi qu'ils aient
encore raison de la nouveauté loyers ont
ça s'annonce est une bombe complotistes
de prendre encore pas que ça relève de
la mercedes sls que vos collègues ont le
droit d'y répondre quand même ou alors
ce sujet est clos parce que vous avez
décidé de le clore